[Musique]
james n'a pas retenu ici un coup vernis
touques sur l'habitude champ
c'est un chasseur un guide un
spécialiste du terrain
dans le cadre d'une initiative locale
est la même des contrevenants sur le
territoire chasser pêcher pour
construire une cabane il leur donne
l'occasion de renouer avec leurs racines
pour les convaincre que c'est mieux de
vivre dans la nature que d'être pris
dans une prison du sud
c'est un projet parmi une poignée au
nunavik qui propose des mesures
alternatives à la judiciarisation des
inuits
la surreprésentation des inuits qui
prennent le chemin des tribunaux atteint
aujourd'hui des sommets critique le taux
de détention chez les inuits et presque
six fois plus élevé que celui de tous
les autres groupes autochtones au québec
le système judiciaire est à bout de
souffle il faut pas importer ce qui se
passe au sud ici tout est différent il
joua le clash je bois clair ça
fonctionne pas on diminue pas les doses
ils actuelle en juillet l'isolément du
nord et le manque d'infrastructures font
en sorte que les contrevenants comme
leurs victimes ne reçoivent pas le même
traitement qu'ailleurs au québec les
inuits veulent reprendre les rênes de la
justice au nunavik
comme tout le monde nous voulons prendre
en main notre destin somebody deux
visions qui s'opposent celle du sud et
celle du nord à la croisée des chemins
[Musique]
georges bach a fait des compétitions de
motoneige et de traîneaux à chiens et
les soucis un chasseur expérimenté qui
partage ses prises avec les voisins dans
le besoin
[Musique]
le système de justice il a appris à le
connaître d'abord comme policier il ya
une quinzaine d'années
à groupe
prônait
blick
mais après trois ans il quitte la police
puis un soir en 2011 c'est vie dérape
dans un accès de colère il s'en prend à
un ex collègue
se prenait pas du
jour au lendemain jones se retrouve de
l'autre côté de la clôture il a eu à
affronter les nombreuses embûches qui
caractérise le système de justice au
nunavik en commençant par les délais de
comparution
[Musique]
plusieurs avocats de la défense nous ont
dit que les délais dépasse encore
couramment la limite de trois jours
comme l'exigent pourtant le code
criminel malgré l'instauration en 2020
de la visioconférence pendant la
pandémie
il n'y a pas de centre de détention
permanent au nunavik les accusés qui
attendent leur procès sont donc
transporté à des milliers de kilomètres
à saint jérôme dans les laurentides ou à
amos en abitibi
bien loin de leur communauté
[Musique]
vingt
six ans
[Musique]
pour la tenue des procès c'est le
système de justice qui doit se déplacer
des dizaines de fois par année dans 9
des 14 communautés du nunavik c'est ce
qu'on appelle la cour itinérant
adopté en 1974 dans la foulée de la
crise la baie james la cour itinérante
avait pour but de rendre la justice
accessible aux peuples du nord mais elle
est depuis longtemps affublé du surnom
peu flatteur de cirque volant
jean pierre larose a fait presque
quarante ans de service dans la région
de montréal avant d'être recrutée en
2018 par la police régional du nunavik
il en est le chef et directeur de la
sécurité publique la cour itinérante
[Musique]
ici au nunavik je crois qu'elle fait son
possible mais à mon avis mon constat
c'est que elle est un peu dépassé et on
a des seins volume de dossiers
incroyable depuis que je suis arrivé ça
le presque doublé
sur une population de 9 mais l'adulte
mais le 400 d'entre eux sont accusés au
criminel chaque année en moyenne la
grande majorité des causes sont liées à
des problèmes sociaux comme la pénurie
de logements et la toxicomanie il s'agit
d'un taux de judiciarisation fin fois
plus élevé que pour l'ensemble du québec
on peut le voir le livre rôle en ce
moment on arrive ici il peut avoir
jusqu'à 250 personnes qui vont se
présenter devant la cour chaque semaine
de cours
[Musique]
début octobre au palais de justice de
coup droit que les défaillances du
système se font sentir
comme vous avez pu voir la semaine de
course la pluie écroulé comme un château
de cartes d'un malheureusement
comme c'est souvent le cas dans nord la
météo fait des caprices les vents
empêche les avions transportant accusés
et témoins de décoller d'un autre
village et dizaines de causes devront
être portées et c'est loin d'être une
situation exceptionnelle
le juge qui siège pour la première fois
ici c'est un des nombreux délais au
calendrier
[Musique]
c'est parce que
personne n'y a pas de juge
ce détenu vient d'arriver de saint
jérôme au palais de justice de coup
droit qu avec 24 heures de retard pour
sa date prévue en cours on s'était
trompé de prisonniers et on avait
préparé le voyage de nos autres
personnes une fois l'erreur découverte
on s'est précipité pour faire acheminer
le bon prévenu est à le faire voyager
pendant plus de 18 heures
son avocat a télé un fabre héros est
parti je pense à saint-jérôme hier à 16h
puma d'arrivée amos dans la nuit puis
ensuite ils m'ont réveillé pour le
ramener à coups de jacques ce matin donc
on prend là qu'il est debout depuis 3h
du matin pour moi y'a g
la nuit mais malgré tout il n'a jamais
pu être entendu la juge qui ne siège pas
régulièrement la cour itinérante a
préféré ne pas s'engager dans un projet
dont elle n'aurait pu assurer le suivi
si vous n'êtes pas capable je m'embarque
au latin japon pour faire un voyage pour
sauter mon fils ça fait quand même temps
qu'il est en détention sans savoir que
quand est-ce que baron sont proches
savaient depuis juillet ça fait trois
mois et puis l'idée c'était d'avancer le
plus vite possible alors c'est sûr que
c'est décevant
sa cause est donc remise de plusieurs
mois car la cour itinérante repassera
avec un autre juge entre temps il doit
reprendre le long chemin de la prison de
saint-jérôme
oui c'est problématique le fait qu'aucun
centre de détention d'un chrono du
québec laurent rivet est avocat la
défense c'est quand même très difficile
quand les gens vivent beaucoup de joie
qui doivent être transportés à amorce un
gironde par famille sont pas en mesure
de leur amener puisqu'ils vêtements et
autres donc ceci est assez problématique
j'ai beaucoup de famille qui m'appelle
parfois pour assez de savoir comment ils
peuvent entrer en contact avec leurs
enfants qui sont détenus
depuis passé 20 jours à la prison d'amos
avant son audience pour remise en
liberté lors du procès l'avocat embauché
à ses frais réussi à lui obtenir une
peine de détention à domicile il a évité
d'être exilé par une prison du sud
au
sud le tribunal peut accorder des peines
qui sont purgées de façon intermittente
mais pas une une vie qu
[Musique]
on n'est pas en mesure de donner des
sentences discontinue vers l'emv 92
après permet aux personnes de maintenir
leurs emplois et devenir leur période de
détention pendant les quatre semaines
sur les cinq ans qui sont couramment
d'aller dans tous les autres districts
judiciaires malheureusement qu'on peut
pas le faire avant la grandeur du québec
mais oui clairement s'ils prennent la
même façon de fonctionner à longueuil
cas que tu vois qu'un
ouais
[Musique]
nous sommes au poste de police de pau
vernis touques cette communauté
d'environ 1800 habitants enregistre l'un
des taux les plus élevés de violence
conjugale et de suicide au québec
ici des cellules de détention temporaire
sont souvent surpeuplées les détenus
transporté d'amos pour une comparution
ou un procès s'ajoutent aux arrestations
du jour il peut y avoir six ou sept
détenus dans une seule de ces cellules
afin de réduire les arrestations liées à
des facteurs sociaux comme des conflits
familiaux le service de police et les
services de santé se sont alliés pour
former une équipe composée d'un policier
et d'un travailleur social depuis 2019
ils prennent la route cinq soirs par
semaine
[Musique]
pour l'instant pas crise a signalé dans
la communauté
l'équipe s'arrête à une maison pour
faire le suivi d'une intervention
récente
l'objectif de cette patrouille est
simple on veut calmer les esprits
désamorcer les conflits et diriger les
gens crise vers des ressources en santé
au lieu du poste de police
à l'ennemi canine ex chef de police du
nunavik est aujourd'hui gestionnaire de
projet pour le compte du ministère de la
santé c'est elle qui a créé ce programme
mais une personne à l'hôpital dans une
autre maison ou simplement discuter avec
elle on a vu une réduction du nombre de
personnes qui aboutissent en détention
ils aident à rétablir les relations dans
la communauté
le service de police de nous n'avait crû
de presque tout son personnel au sud et
le lien de confiance avec les inuits
reste toujours fragile
j'ai du travail à faire je mets
policiers aussi en termes de culture et
d'accrocher tout ça parce que j'ai
beaucoup de jeunes policiers
inexpérimentés qui sont formés dans une
perspective urbaine faut comprendre par
où ils ont passé pour mieux intervenir
djinnit mais en a long à dire sur la
justice ont une vie qu elle fait partie
d'une des familles les plus connus dans
la région
sa pente mais oui mais ça y mène est la
gouverneure générale du canada
un choix rappelé un conflit conjugal qui
n'y avaient lancé un appel à l'aide mais
elle dit que les forces de l'ordre n'ont
pas pris ses ennuis au sérieux
de police
[Musique]
pour les procureurs dont le rôle est de
soutenir les victimes et de traduire les
responsables en justice la tâche est
lourde
l'éloignement géographique aussi fait
que ça c'est difficile pour nous de
créer le contact avec les plaignants
avec les victimes
le taux de roulement parmi la vingtaine
d'avocats qui travaille au nunavik est
élevé le bureau d'amos qui fournit les
services juridiques dans nord du québec
a vu partir 14 procureur depuis 2019
quand je suis arrivé avec les procureurs
de la couronne qui étaient ici en
permanence ils ne sont plus ici il y
avait là juridiques qu'ils ont quitté
également on a besoin de services
supplémentaires mais on y va en nous
emmenant les aphtes oui une cour de
justice permanent mais transformé par
une cour de justice comme on voit au sud
elle doit être adaptée à la culture et
impliquer les inuits dans le processus
et il n'y a que les inuit avaient leur
propre façon de régler les problèmes
dans la communauté canning
la société mce ii représente les inuits
du nunavik auprès des gouvernements du
canada et du québec
l'organisme a signé un protocole avec
québec pour mettre sur pied des comités
de justice dont l'émission est
d'expliquer le processus judiciaire au
contrevenant est d'offrir des mesures de
rechange axé sur la justice réparatrice
et l'harmonie collective
ces images d'un comité et tourné dans le
cadre d'une vidéo promotionnelle nous
ont été fournies par makivik
rencontre le contrevenant et on l'aide à
comprendre ses droits en utilisant notre
culture comme on l'a toujours fait
eugene hardcore ah oui des deux n'a pas
les ressources en matière de prévention
sont insuffisantes selon les
intervenants qui nous avons parlé
dans son rapport de 2016 le protecteur
du citoyen note que la judiciarisation
ne règle pas les problèmes de fond
telles que la toxicomanie et la violence
conjugale et que les peines ont un effet
plus dissuasif sur les personnes
souffrant de dépendances c'est le ping
septembre au lieu d'envoyer les gens au
sud pour conduite avec facultés
affaiblies
on pourrait gérer ça dans notre
communauté en trouvant nos propres
solutions chez les seniors 2
- 2 2 % des causes sont transférés au
comité de justice chaque année surtout
des infractions mineures comme des
méfaits des vols ou des menaces
la vaste majorité des infractions le non
respect des conditions les quatre
conduites avec facultés affaiblies et
les conflits familiaux aboutissent
devant les tribunaux au sein du
protocole il ya eu la main assez pas
tout les crimes qui sont référés à bhl
c'est nous les procureurs terrain qui
vont référé les dossiers mais on le fait
dans la limite de ce qui est autorisé
par ce protocole mais pour l'instant
c'est le cadre dans lequel on doit
travailler
en aide aux petits tout le mot c'est
yauque me dire faire tourner le vent
c'est le nom qu'on a donné un programme
qui comme les comités de justice propose
une alternative à la judiciarisation
valorisant la réhabilitation des
contrevenants par des pratiques
traditionnelles
ces intervenants revient d'une chasse
aux morses dans l'hébétude sont leurs
clients celui qui a tué l'animal a eu
des démêlés avec la justice
on travaille à préparer des poches de
viande qui fermente rond pendant deux
mois avant d'être servis lors d'un
festin communautaire
[Musique]
ce programme a fait ses preuves il
commence tout juste à s'implanter dans
quelques autres communautés
le programme néo z parce qu'on les tient
occupés quand on va chasser on est
épuisés à la fin de la journée en
ramenant du gibier il retrouve un
sentiment de fierté il le partageront
non seulement avec leurs familles mais
aussi avec la communauté
ça fonctionne parce que certaines nos
clients ne sont pas retournés au système
de justice aux dates choisies
[Musique]
makivik la société qui chapeaute et
programmes de justice alternative un
vrai qu'on élargisse le nombre
d'infractions admissibles et que le
gouvernement leur accorde plus de
financements
d'assystem has to adapt tout le système
doit s'adapter à la région et mettre en
place les infrastructures nécessaires au
lieu de faire voyager la cour itinérante
ocz c'est pourquoi je dis qu'il faut
avoir notre propre système en place six
canettes même administré
quelques semaines après notre passage au
nunavik le ministre de la justice y
mange la barrette a nommé un rapporteur
conjointement avec makivik pour se
pencher sur la situation
lieu déjà beaucoup d'échos de rapport
critique sur la situation de justice au
nunavik au fil des décennies pourquoi un
autre rapport à ce stade-ci dans les
rapports souvent c'est les grands
princes contre arrivée mois avec des
solutions pratiques aux pratiques qui
vont être un réel âmes qui seront pas du
pelletage nuages puis qui vont nous
permettre vraiment d'avancé et pourquoi
on changerait pas nos pratiques pour
faire en sorte que ça fonctionne mieux
qu'il y ait une adhésion système de
justice des membres de la communauté une
nouvelle parce que vous êtes prêt à voir
un changement structurel qui donnerait
plus de pouvoir aux inuits sur leur
système de justice est ouvert à des
modalités qui vont faire en sorte de
pouvoir adapter le système de justice
mais sur le fait de déléguer ses
pouvoirs là il faut juste faire
attention pour être certain que la
justice sur le territoire québécois
s'applique de la même façon il faut
jamais oublier que sur le territoire
québécois c'est le rôle de l'état
québécois de devenir administrer la
justice
[Musique]
jack est conscient de la chance qu'il a
eue de pouvoir purger sa peine chez lui
et d'avoir eu l'autorisation de la cour
de s'occuper de ses chiens
[Musique]
l'ancien policier participe actuellement
la création d'un groupe de défense des
droits des inuits en matière de santé
d'éducation et d'accès à la justice
de son
modèle
politique
canadienne shy'm est finie
[Musique]